THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Secretary Kirby: MY
PLEASURE.
>> Sandra: WE THANK HIM FOR
JOINING US.
ENERGY SECURITY HAS BEEN AT THE
CENTER OF THIS ENTIRE CONFLICT.
JOINING US NOW FROM A VERY
ENERGY RICH STATE, LOUISIANA
SENATOR BILL CASSIDY.
SENATOR, WELCOME TO YOU AND
WELCOME TO FOX NEWS SUNDAY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> Senator Cassidy: THANK YOU
FOR HAVING MEET.
SAW MY INTERVIEW WITH DON KIRBY
ON THE ESCALATING
TENSIONS.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE AWAY FROM
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD?
>> Senator Cassidy: THIS IS A
CULMINATION OF THE UNITED STATES
DEARMING WHEN IT COMES TO ENERGY
DIPLOMACY.
LESS THAN ONE YEAR AGO UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION, WE WERE
NOT ONLY ENERGY INDEPENDENT, BUT
POISED TO BECOME AND HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THE E.U. ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
IN LESS THAN A YEAR, WE’VE LOST
THAT ABILITY.
RUSSIA HAS THE LEVERAGE OVER THE
E.U. IN TERMS OF ENERGY SUPPLY
IN ORDER TO BLACKMAIL THEM AND
TURNING A BLIND EYE.
YOU COULD ARGUE THEY ARE TRYING
NOT TO, BUT GERMANY’S RESPONSE
HAS BEEN QUITE MUTED TO THE
PENDING INVASION.
I WOULD SAY THIS IS A
CULMINATION OF A FOLD ENERGY
POLICY.
>> Sandra: OTHERS HAVE SAID IS
IT LEVERAGE THAT WE MAKE IT OUT
TO BE?
GAS IS NOT YET FLOWING THROUGH
THAT PIPELINE.
IT’S NOT CURRENTLY A REVENUE
SOURCE FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IS IT AS MUCH OF A LEDGE AS MANY
ARE MAKING OUT TO BE?
>> Senator Cassidy: THEY’RE
STILL THE FIRST AND THERE’S
LIQUEFIED GAS SHIPMENTS.
BY THE WAY, ENERGY PRICE SIGNS
ARE MUCH HIGHER IN EUROPE RIGHT
NOW THAN THEY ARE AND THAT’S
HAVING AN IMPACT ON ON THE
POCKETBOOK AND ECONOMY.
WE’VE ALREADY SEEN A HINT OF THE
LEVERAGE AND IT COULD INCREASE
IF THE RUSSIANS DECIDED TO
FURTHER EXPLOIT.
>> Sandra: SENATOR, THE
PRESIDENT IS STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING, AND YOU HEARD US
TALK ABOUT IT A MOMENT AGO,
ENCOURAGING AMERICANS IN UKRAINE
TO LEAVE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
SAYS THAT THERE IS NO PROSPECT
FOR A U.S. MILITARY LED A
EVACUATION INSIDE UKRAINE.
SHOULD THE U.S. BE DOING MORE
ABOUT THIS?
>> Senator Cassidy: I AGREE
WITH THE PRESIDENT 100%.
USE COMMON SENSE.
WE SHOULD NOT BE ENDANGERING OUR
SOLDIERS OR MARINES BECAUSE
SOMEBODY DECIDES NOT TO EVACUATE
UNTIL AFTER THE FACT.
GET OUT!
IF THERE IS A PENDING INVASION,
USED COMMON SENSE AND LEAVE.
>> Sandra: THE PRESIDENT
VOWING TO END THE NORDSTREAM
PIPELINE IF RUSSIA INVADES.
GERMANY SAYS IT IS UNITED WITH
THE U.S. IN THAT DECISION.
HE DID SO WAS STANDING NEXT TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IF THAT PIPELINE, AS WE JUST
DISCUSSED, IT REMAINS HALTED,
GERMANY WILL CLEAN ON OTHER
FOREIGN NATIONS FOR A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THEIR
ENERGY NEEDS.
WHAT CAN WE BE DOING ON A
COUNTRY TODAY KNOWING THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE AND CAN
TAP INTO AS YOU JUST MENTIONED.
WHAT CAN WE BE DOING FOR
PREPARING ON WHAT WILL LIKELY BE
AN ENERGY CRISIS IN EUROPE IF
RUSSIA INVADES?
>> Senator Cassidy: WE MUST
RESUME USING AMERICA’S RESOURCES
AND RAMPING THEM UP IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE OR REPLACE THAT WHICH
RUSSIA WOULD PROVIDE.
BY THE WAY, THAT MEANS BEGINNING
TO LEASE IN THE OUTER
CONTINENTAL SHELF OFF OF
LOUISIANA.
ALLOWING DEVELOPMENT OF OIL AND
NATURAL GAS AND PUBLIC LANDS
ONLY INLAND AND SPEEDING UP
PERMANENT FOR THE EXPORT
FACILITIES AND PIPELINES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY NOT OCCURRING.
IT CAN ALSO INCLUDE, BY THE WAY,
PERMITTING FOR THE RENEWABLES TO
BE ABLE TO SHIP THEIR ELECTRONS.
RIGHT NOW, THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS PUTTING IN AMBER THE ABILITY
OF THE U.S. TO EXPAND AND ENERGY
SUPPLY.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE PAYING MORE
FOR GAS AND NATURAL GAS.
IT’S WHY THE E.U.’S.
WE HAVE TO EASE THAT NOT ONLY
FOR OURSELVES, BUT THE E.U.
>> Sandra: YOUR HOME STATE OF
LOUISIANA PROVIDES MORE NATURAL
GAS EXPORTS THAN ANY OTHER U.S.
STATE.
WE KNOW YOU HAVE ACCESS TO A
WHOLE LOT MORE.
YOU AND A FEW OTHER REPUBLICAN
SENATORS MET THIS WEEK WITH THE
E.U. COMMISSIONER FOR ENERGY.
WERE THERE ANY PROMISES MADE
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO MEET
EUROPE’S ENERGY NEEDS IN THE
FUTURE?
>> Senator Cassidy: SENATORS
CANNOT PROMISE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION SLOW WALKS
EVERYTHING BY EVERY MEANS
POSSIBLE TO DECREASE U.S. ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN TAKE LAWS
ON THE BOOK AND INTERPRET THEM
IN SUCH A WAY, SOMETIMES IN
DIRECT CONFLICT WITH A STATED
MEANS OF THE LAW, TO SLOW DOWN
PRODUCTION.
THAT IS WHAT THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS DOING.
THEY ARE DOING IT IN THE WEIGHT
OF LOWER INTENSITY SO NOW,
GERMANY’S BURNING COAL INSTEAD
OF NATURAL GAS.
NOT ONLY ARE WE GETTING MORE
CARBON INTENSITY, BUT WE ARE
PUTTING OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES AT
THREAT OF ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND
ALLOWING THEM TO BE LEVERAGED BY
RUSSIA.
THIS ADMINISTRATION’S ENERGY
POLICY IS A FAILURE IN TERMS OF
THE CLIMATES, AND TERMS OF
NATIONAL SECURITY, THE ECONOMY,
IN TERMS OF YOU NAME IT.
>> Sandra: SENATOR, I WANT TO
MOVE ON TO THE GREAT MASK THE
BAIT.
WE SAW A LOT OF IT THIS WEEK.
THIS WEEK, WE SAID DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN’S DROPPING ARE
WINDING DOWN INDOOR SCHOOL
MATHEMATICS.
IN LOUISIANA, THE GOVERNOR HAS
ENCOURAGED MASK WEARING, BUT HE
SAYS THAT SCHOOLS CAN OPT OUT OF
MASKS AS LONG AS A FELLOW CDC
QUARANTINE GARDEN LIGHTS.
IF THE CDC AND THE WHITE HOUSE
ARE RECOMMENDING WEARING MASKS
IN HIGH TRANSMISSION AREAS.
IT INDICATES COMMUNITY RISK
RIGHT NOW IS VERY HIGH ALL OVER
THE STATE.
SHOULD KIDS BE WEARING MASKS IN
LOUISIANA SCHOOLS?
>> Senator Cassidy: WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
IF THE SCIENCE SAYS THAT MASKS
ARE ONLY A MARGINAL BENEFIT BUT
THE COST OF THE CHILD IS OF MORE
THAN MARGINAL COST, WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
I WILL SAY THAT.
CLEARLY, WHAT HAS HAPPENED OVER
THE PAST YEAR, CHILDREN HAVE
SUFFERED FROM BEING LOCKED OUT
OF SCHOOLS AND IN SOME STATES
WEARING THE MASK.
I’M A DOCTOR AND THAT’S WHAT I
BELIEVE.
THAT’S WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
>> Sandra: AND THAT’S WHAT
MAKES YOU A VERY UNIQUE SENATOR.
HAVING THAT EMPTY.
WE HAVE SEEN MAJOR BATTLES
PLAYING OUT OVER WHO HAS FINAL
SAY ON MASK MANDATES FOR THE
CHILDREN, SCHOOLS OR GOVERNORS.
AND YOUR HOME STATE, SCHOOL MASK
MANDATE DECISIONS ARE LEFT UP TO
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IS THAT THE RIGHT APPROACH OR
SHOULD GOVERNORS BE ABLE TO
SUPERSEDE LOCAL AUTHORITIES AS
WE HAVE SEEN IN STATES LIKE
VIRGINIA?
>> Senator Cassidy: I’M A
CONSERVATIVE.
I THINK THAT HE OR SHE THAT
GOVERNS CLOSEST TO THOSE GOVERN
GOVERNS BEST.
I THINK THAT SHOULD BE A LOCAL
DECISION AND I SAY THAT AS A
CONSERVATIVE.
>> Jim: GREAT TO HEAR FROM